you guys recently made an appearance in
Fortune magazine as one of the top
places to work and you trumpeted some of
your diversity numbers and I want you to
share those with us because I think
they're really important because you've
worked really hard to diversify your own
organization thank you we were so
excited to be included in this national
ranking of best places to work for women
so we ranked number 50 in our first year
on the list and it was truly a dream
come true for me I included in that were
our gender stature would serve well
above the average we've known this for a
while so across the board overall 5050
almost exactly technical 25% still
working on that and also executives
forty percent so it was exciting to see
that a nod to that because it has been a
big part of our culture for now almost
ten years it's interesting jamaat poly
Hypatia the social capital partnership
just came out with a new list today
called the future list ranking venture
capital firms by gender age and in their
own level of diversity and it was pretty
dismal I mean we already know that the
number the numbers aren't great in
venture capital when it comes to women
but you know what's your reaction to
something like this you walk down the
halls of a venture capital firm or any
traditional financial institution you'll
notice something they have a lot of work
to do to get to where companies like
eventbrite are today I think that it's
actually not about the VC firms though
it's about the number of women founders
and the number of women leaders role
models that's the most potent form of
changing gender equality when I look at
Elizabeth Holmes or melody Hobbs exactly
by the way or the second female founder
on our show today so you guys are doing
pretty well but it's hard I'm you know
it's hard to be a working mother it's
hard to be a foundering you put those
two together you have a hard proposition
but the more and more that I see these
types of women wall models around me the
more I feel empowered so I up were down
three principles make sure we have great
role models at eventbrite make sure that
as a company we're building the
infrastructure to really support working
parents overall and then three be honest
with ourselves when we have an area that
we need to work on
let's talk about eventbrite 200 billion
in global ticket sales talk about the
momentum and why keeps building well you
know what we've tapped on now for again
almost nine years is this wide gap
between the big incumbent ticketing
providers and the do-it-yourself methods
of emails Fred chic guest list and that
gap was very large we're a
multi-category ticketing platform and
there's a real use for that in the world
give tens of millions of active
consumers who are actually coming back
to eventbrite to find great life
experiences and I think what we've keyed
in on is that humans like to connect
it's why they come to events like this
summit we need that connection and so
that's our vision is to bring the world
together through ticketing and it turns
out it's a great business as well as
event friday unicorn do you embrace that
designation well I guess there was a
definition put upon us right i feel like
we're pretty magical um but you know it
for us it's about can we fulfill our
promise to our investors into ourselves
that we can drive real value through
this notion of bringing the world
together the fundraising climate shifts
tomorrow are you guys okay what do you
do to a day are probably that the
proudest I've been of the company has
been in the last nine months so before
it was a sexy topic we were going after
efficiency because we could see the
writing on the wall this isn't at our Co
found my co-founder and our CEOs first
rodeo so we knew that we needed to make
ourselves foolproof if we want to stay
independent so we're doing where I
really happy to say we're doing okay and
we're on that path two independent so
you know but you and I've been talking
about this for years now you've said you
eventbrite will go public you will be a
public company one of the things Bill
girlie of bed parkside on stage today is
a company should operate as if they are
going public someday this idea that
you'd never have to go public is is
unhealthy so you know what's your
response to that and what are your plans
now well speaking of health I think it's
really important to build a healthy
organization and I do agree with Bill
girlie that we should be operating as if
we want to go public tomorrow we don't
want to go public tomorrow but we
actually are getting ourselves ready to
be at
sustainable independent company with
optionality that works in both the
private markets and the public markets
and the idea is that you can't rely on
capital markets for your growth you have
to start to self-fund your own growth
and that's really what we're keying in
on that it's again very unsexy in the
valley to talk about right now but
efficiency is something that is number
one if you're going to stay independent
right and I think that's just a totally
different ball game it's not about being
sexy it's about building a great
business that's right